ah
[Música]
hola qué tal gracias
muchas gracias muy amables
lo que acaba de escuchar en un fragmento
de una pieza titulada agua y mediante
algunos de sus fragmentos quiero
contaros acerca de cómo la música puede
ser una muy poderosa herramienta para
transformar y mejorar esta sociedad que
desgraciadamente cada vez se encamina
más hacia lo que tenemos en lugar de
hacia lo que somos o sentimos nos ha
tocado vivir en una época materialista
qué duda cabe basta con echar un vistazo
a las redes sociales a los medios de
comunicación a la publicidad para darnos
cuenta de que continuamente nos
bombardean con la idea de que el éxito
reside en ganar mucho dinero o si no
mucho al menos el suficiente para poder
comprar coches para casas hipotecas
tablas de última generación y no de
viaje a punta cana qué sé yo mi pregunta
realmente merece la pena quiero decir
para llegar a ese punto la mayoría de la
gente tiene que trabajar muchísimas
horas en empleos que en ocasiones no les
satisfacen plenamente o que directamente
detectan sólo para tener la sensación de
que todo ese enorme esfuerzo tiene su
recompensa en el último modelo de
'smartphone' la escapada de fin de
semana yo creo firmemente que las
personas no somos lo que poseemos o no
deberíamos serlo si creo que hacemos lo
que sentimos
somos emociones andantes
con patitas y una de las formas más
bonitas de experimentar una gama casi
infinita de emociones es a través de la
música la música llega donde las
palabras se quedan cortas y en un
lenguaje universal capaz de conmover
prácticamente a cualquier persona
diréis claro como músico que nos va a
decirnos bueno
esto va más allá de ser una simple
opinión personal son numerosísimos los
estudios científicos que ponen de
manifiesto los casi innumerables
beneficios que aporta por ejemplo
aprender a tocar un instrumento musical
o el simple hecho de escuchar música por
puro placer mejora de la capacidad
auditiva obviamente de la comunicación
verbal de la lógica matemática de la
coordinación motora que para un tío
torpe como yo eso se agradece
y reducción de la ansiedad del estrés
donde los grandes males de este siglo
son algunos de los beneficios más
evidentes pero fijaros que ni mucho
menos son los únicos ni siquiera los más
importantes en el tratamiento de una
enfermedad tan terrible y devastadora
como el alzhéimer la música está
teniendo un papel destacadísimo se está
estudiando como los recuerdos musicales
generan los previos a la aparición de la
enfermedad son inmunes a los efectos de
estas incluso en su fase más avanzada es
fascinante enfermos que no recuerdan su
propio nombre que no reconocen a sus
familiares más allegados si rememoran
perfectamente aquellas canciones que en
su día les emocionaron puede que décadas
atrás
si alguna vez llega la cura del
alzheimer a través de la música y creo
que ese día llegará sinceramente será un
acto casi de justicia poética y ese día
yo me reconcilia un poquito con el mundo
bien volviendo al tema del inicio el
agua es toda una declaración de
intenciones es una reivindicación de la
sencillez no solamente en lo musical
sino como forma de vida químicamente el
agua una de las sustancias más simples
de la naturaleza solamente la molécula
de hidrógeno son combinadas con una de
oxígeno y uno soy químico h2o no pero
bueno creo que no lo sabemos casi tengo
lo hago todo y ya está nada más
y nada menos a ver es que sin agua no
existiría vida no estaríamos aquí
ninguno de nosotros nos había organizado
del realejo imaginas qué drama no
y creo que deberíamos tomar nota del
mensaje que la naturaleza nos está
enviando
en lo sencillo está lo realmente
importante luego lo esencial
yo utilizo el concepto de agua como una
metáfora de la condición humana de cómo
nuestras emociones fluyen de una forma
similar al líquido elemento y en
ocasiones también se estanca en esta
comparación esta metáfora que queda muy
chula no la ha inventado yo sino que se
le ha tomado prestada a bruce lee el
libro se llamaba acordáis de aquella
famosa cita célebre que pronunció así lo
tenemos aquí aquí la tenemos dice no te
establezca en una forma adaptarla
construye la tuya propia y déjala crecer
ese como el agua vacía tu mente se
amorfo moldeable como el agua si pones
agua en una taza se convierte en la taza
si pones algo en una botella se
convierte en la botella si la pones en
una tetera se convierte en la tetera el
agua puede fluir o puede aplastar se
cómo el agua amigo porque el agua que
corre nunca se estanca así que hay que
seguir fluyendo bien como yo no soy
quien para llevarle la contraria brolin
vamos a seguir fluyendo vamos a hacer un
pequeño análisis que va establecer
conexiones entre lo musical y lo
emocional veréis a lo que me refiero
agua comienza con una sencillísimas
notas
casi etéreas que apenas rozan en las
teclas del piano son como unas gotas
bien podría ser una idea en fase inicial
un pensamiento una emoción porque no
también una pequeña preocupación o un
problema apenas perceptible
a continuación entra en juego la mano
izquierda mediante unos sencillos
arpegios la armonía va a ir
desarrollándose del mismo modo que
nuestra idea va tomando forma el agua
empieza a fluir sin prisa pero sin pausa
llegados a este punto la mano izquierda
se va a tornar más grave y más oscura
más intensa es curioso porque de un
punto de vista puramente técnico
armónico la progresión de acordes que
vaya a escuchar es idéntica a la del
fragmento que acabo de interpretar sin
embargo nosotros la vamos a percibir
como si fuese distinta más oscura como
si nos dijese que algo se avecina
nuestra mente funciona de una forma muy
similar ante un mismo hecho somos
nosotros los que muchas veces rumiando y
anticipándonos a lo que va a pasar le
damos más importancia dentro de nuestra
loca cabecita de lo que luego realmente
tiene
a continuación la lluvia entra en escena
una lluvia tenue constante finita las
notas de la mano derecha se hacen más
repetitivas un poco más veloces mientras
que las de la mano izquierda
van a alternar solamente entre dos
arpegios 22 acordes
[Música]
a partir de ahora la lluvia va a ganar
en intensidad como lo van a hacer las
notas de la mano derecha cada vez más
intensas y más agudas por contra las de
la mano izquierda van a continuar en
esos dos mismos arpegios anteriores
dando cierta ideas de estancamiento de
no poder vivir de esa situación de tener
que hacerle frente en este punto de
cierta vulnerabilidad o fragilidad llega
el que en mi humilde opinión es el
momento musical más bonito de la pieza y
creo que no es casualidad porque yo
siempre encontré mucha belleza en los
frágiles
[Música]
ya está aquí la tormenta es cuestión de
tiempo de segundos que llegue veréis
como las notas de la mano derecha se
vuelven cada vez más veloces más
intensas más agudas por contra las de la
izquierdas van a mantener esos dos
mismos arpegios anteriores aumentando
aún más si cabe esa sensación de
estancamiento de estar a merced de los
elementos en este punto creo que lo más
inteligente que podemos hacer es lo que
haríamos en la vida real aguantar
estoicamente el chaparrón y confiar en
que todo se resuelva el que resiste gana
bien
[Música]
bien esa era es la tormenta bueno lo que
parecía una tempestad insalvable la fila
no ha sido para tanto y sobre todo lo
más importante tenemos la experiencia y
vamos a comprobar que en esta pieza
musical como casi siempre
en la vida después de la tormenta viene
la calma que todo pasa y que todo llega
[Música]
si os dais cuenta en realidad no estaba
hablando sobre agua sino sobre emociones
con esta información os voy a
interpretar la pieza ahora al completo
sin interrupción en ningún tipo de
comentario
solamente música y nada más y nada menos
y quiero que la escuchéis por favor con
los ojos cerrados si no ninguna
aplicación aquí es la pesca que cada
cual visualizo imaginé aquello que
libremente le venga a su imaginación sin
ningún tipo de pretensión y de ataduras
se trata precisamente de fluir como el
agua
es posible que dentro de cuatro minutos
os sintáis más relajados más emocionados
al menos desespero y será casi mágico
comprobar como algo intangible como son
notas acordes melodías provocarán una
serie de reacciones químicas en vuestros
cerebros que a su vez repercutirán a
nivel emocional e incluso también físico
durante cuatro minutos no existirán los
problemas estaremos centrados en el aquí
y en el ahora que no es poco' de hecho
es muchísimo casi nunca lo hacemos
aunque no nos damos cuenta de esto creo
que ese es uno de los grandes poderes de
la música esa su grandeza
lo mejor de todo es que es gratis
tenemos un montón de música al alcance
de nuestra mano totalmente gratis no
deje efectos secundarios negativos al
contrario deja muchísimo creo que todo
es positivo y se puede repetir la dosis
tantas veces se quiera no hay riesgo de
sobredosis por último haciendo caso al
maestro brooklyn
vamos a afluir como el agua muchas
gracias por vuestra atención y por
haberme ayudado a cumplir uno de mis
sueños que era esta charla
sí
e
bueno
[Música]
mira
él
[Música]
y
[Aplausos]